[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie
ed è un onore un piacere essere qui oggi
con voi
per condividere alcune riflessioni su
quello che sta accadendo nel mondo del
lavoro nella leadership quindi la
ricerca di un nuovo equilibrio che si è
rotto per sempre durante la pandemia e
non solo
Santiago del Cile notte siamo nel buio
della pandemia in un periodo in cui
tutti
annelano a tornare una normalità
un gruppo di artisti Proietta su un
edificio di Santiago questa frase non
volveremo sarà normali Dad purché la
normalità era il problema
questa frase
vista con gli occhi di oggi e con gli
occhi del mondo del lavoro delle aziende
assume secondo me un carattere profetico
quindi questo gruppo di artisti aveva
visto qualcosa aveva sentito
probabilmente qualcosa che non andava
perché in effetti se c'è una cosa che è
successa
nel mondo che siamo tornati a fare tutto
quello che facevamo prima del covip
siamo tornati al ristorante al cinema al
teatro siamo tornati a scuola ma c'è una
cosa sola su cui non siamo più tornati a
fare quello che facevamo prima non siamo
più tornati al lavoro ovviamente abbiamo
continuato a lavorare per fortuna Ma non
siamo più tornati a lavorare come
lavoravamo prima del covip quindi è
successo qualcosa di
profondamente
disruptive che ha cambiato per sempre il
mondo del lavoro
e probabilmente quella frase quegli
artisti
sentivano No un termometro la
temperatura che stava salendo il
malessere che nel mondo del lavoro
continuava a crescere
però cosa è successo che forse non
l'abbiamo visto in tempo Forse ci siamo
preoccupati più
dei sintomi che non delle cause No qui
se ne vedono alcuni no che si sente
ormai da un po' di tempo parlare
diffusamente di questi concetti Iolo
Quindi io Holiday once si vive una volta
sola quindi basta i compromessi che
abbiamo accettato per troppo tempo
Voglio un giusto bilanciamento vita
professionale vita personale voglio
coltivare le mie passioni basta
dedicarsi 100% alla causa del lavoro
abbiamo il fenomeno del Quiet quitting
lascio l'azienda senza lasciarla
fenomeno bruttissimo quindi di
disingaggio di non sentirsi più parte di
un'azienda stare alla finestra e vivere
la quotidianità Sperando in
un'opportunità oppure la grade
Communication no ormai come aziende ci
stiamo facendo i conti in maniera
profonda Ma è un fenomeno che si sta
diffondendo in maniera clamorosa cioè
tantissimi ragazzi e ragazze oggi
lasciano il lavoro e lo lasciano senza
avere delle alternative nella mia
generazione questo non era Ma neanche
pensabile No prima di lasciare il lavoro
di dare le dimissioni si vuole alle
offerte in mano la sicurezza eccetera
altrimenti mai più si sarebbe
abbandonato un posto di lavoro e oggi
questo accade e per darvi l'idea della
profondità e della dimensione del
fenomeno un dato non voglio condividere
dati siamo abituati in azienda ma nel
solo 2022 in Italia 2 milioni e 200 mila
persone hanno lasciato le loro aziende
il lavoro e questo per darvi la
dimensione è quasi come la popolazione
della città di Roma quindi come se in un
anno tutti gli abitanti di Roma avessero
abbandonato e lasciato le aziende in cui
lavoravano quindi un fenomeno
incredibilmente Vasto
perché è successo al lavoro perché siamo
tornati a fare tutto quindi perché
quella normalità non era la normalità
che volevamo è stata solo la pandemia
Certamente no la pandemia ha accelerato
ha impresso un'accelerazione incredibile
ma ci ha permesso alle persone di
riprendersi dei momenti di pensare di
rivedere le proprie priorità della vita
di ripensare al progetto di vita che
volevano costruire ma ci sono stati
anche altri due fenomeni che hanno rotto
quell'equilibrio che era rimasto se
vogliamo in piedi per tanti anni per
decenni e decenni e che insieme alla
pandemia hanno dato queste spallate
violente che hanno rotto
quell'equilibrio che sarà stabilizzato
ormai abbiamo vissuto decenni nello
stesso equilibrio del mondo del lavoro e
queste spallate l'hanno completamente
disarcionato la pandemia senz'altro
stato un grande acceleratore ma ci sono
stati anche altri due fenomeni la
rivoluzione tecnologica la rivoluzione
digitale e l'ingresso nel mondo del
lavoro della generazione Z
sulla rivoluzione tecnologica se n'è
parlato tanto sicuramente ci ha dato la
possibilità di sopravvivere una pandemia
incredibilmente impattante ha salvato le
nostre aziende ha salvato le nostre
università le nostre scuole ci ha
permesso di continuare a portare avanti
un percorso seppure in una non normalità
però ci ha dato una grande opportunità a
scardinato per sempre due variabili su
cui il lavoro per secoli si è basato che
erano il concetto di spazio e il
concetto di tempo spazi che erano gli
uffici Le fabbriche ma soprattutto gli
uffici in cui era normale 9 18 lunedì
venerdì lavorare in quelli locali e ha
scardinato il concetto di tempo Qui
siamo in università siamo tornati un po'
tutti studenti chi la preferisce
lavorare di alla sera chi si sveglia la
mattina presto ha scardinato queste due
variabili che per decenni e decenni e
decenni avevano retto un equilibrio nel
mondo del lavoro
ha creato un'accelerazione incredibile
al mondo del lavoro creando per la prima
volta nella storia uno squilibrio tra
domande e offerta mai visto prima
il 78% delle aziende non trova i talenti
che cerca Noi viviamo in questa
situazione ormai da tre anni quindi ci
servono competenze nuove e non le
troviamo quindi c'è uno sbilanciamento
incredibile allo stesso tempo ha creato
un'accelerazione così forte che le
competenze che si cercano non si trovano
e quando si trovano diventa diventano
obsolete nel giro di 3-5 anni quindi per
una generazione come la mia o che mi ha
preceduto che finiva l'università e
acquisiva un bagaglio formativo tale per
cui poteva attraversare tutta la propria
carriera professionale oggi non è più
così quindi chi entra al mondo del
lavoro ha le competenze giuste
e durano per 3-5 anni poi bisogna
ritornare studenti e imparare
abbracciare nuove competenze così
continuare quindi restare studenti per
la vita e questo è un impatto sulle
aziende importanti perché l'azienda
diventeranno sempre più di fatto delle
università Perché dovranno continuare a
rischillare riparare riformare tutti i
lavoratori
una tecnologia che ci fa vivere un
incredibile paradosso no tanti lavori
scompariranno sostituiti la tecnologia
quelli ripetitivi tantissimi lavori
nasceranno ma ad alto contenuto
cognitivo quindi sempre più questo
paradosso di ricerca esasperata delle
competenze formazione continua e
adattamento Ci accompagnerà per tutta la
vita
non da ultimo l'ingresso nel mondo del
lavoro della generazione Z Quindi
abbiamo una forte rappresentanza quindi
nati tra il 96 e il 2010 quindi la prima
parte della generazione Z è ormai
entrata nel mondo del lavoro non solo
entrata Entro il 2025 che da un punto di
vista aziendale è domani la generazione
Z rappresenterà Il 27% della popolazione
lavorativa A livello mondiale Quindi è
una generazione con cui le aziende
dovranno avere a che fare
dovranno includerli e ricostruire
Insieme un progetto una generazione che
ha vissuto voi lo sapete meglio di me
tre anni due tre anni della propria vita
in una fase molto particolare in cui si
cresce si prepara e si costruisce L'uomo
la donna il genitore leader che si sarà
nel futuro
e questo periodo è stato negato Quindi
per una persona come me di 58 anni due
anni e 3 anni sono una parte importante
della mia vita ma non è una parte
fondamentale per un ragazzo e una
ragazza di 20 anni tre anni
rappresentano una percentuale
incredibilmente importante è una
generazione a cui di fatto noi e
leggerazione che ci hanno preceduto
hanno rubato un futuro il futuro con la
F maiuscola noi non siamo nati e
cresciuti con l'idea che il mondo che
abitavamo sarebbe scomparso sarebbe
stato distrutto nel giro di pochi anni
oggi è così e quindi una generazione che
si vede privare il futuro è una
rigenerazione che va guardata con molta
attenzione qui ho trovato una delle
letture degli ultimi periodi una frase
che ho trovato di una attualità e di una
lucidità incredibile
ho letto che era stata citata da
Napoleone poco importa l'importante è il
contenuto e dice per capire un uomo o
una donna guarda al periodo che viveva
in cui quando aveva 20 anni e quindi
questo ci fa riflettere moltissimo su
quelle che sono le generazioni che hanno
vissuto stanno vivendo hanno appena
passato questo mondo quando avevano
vent'anni un mondo Stamattina l'abbiamo
sentito l'acronimo buca incredibilmente
vulnerabile incerto complesso ambiguo un
mondo che vede per la prima volta in
Europa una guerra accadere ancora sul
nostro territorio non lo vedevamo più da
più di 70 anni quindi una generazione
che deve proprio per il ruolo che andrà
a coprire quindi la preponderanza del
futuro
partecipare alla costruzione di quello
che il nuovo futuro e quindi come lo
ricostruiamo questo equilibrio Questa è
una domanda chiaramente impossibile
trovare la risposta oggi si può solo
ipotizzare e mettersi in un cammino per
cercare questa soluzione e quindi cosa
fare
Beh innanzitutto Bisogna capire il
cambiamento
ascoltare le nuove generazioni Non
chiudere gli occhi e provare a costruire
un progetto un percorso però ci sono
tante cose che si possono fare che si
stanno facendo quindi Viva Dio le
aziende come Sentiamo stamattina sono in
movimento stanno diventando sempre più
fluide vivono nel mondo dei paradossi
però tante cose stanno succedendo e
quindi quello che è senz'altro non
possiamo non fare è scardinare quello
che era un po' il modello che vedevamo
che stamattina delle aziende del primo
periodo delle prepandemie Diciamo quindi
con uffici anonimi
con
focalizzati come Obiettivo del Lavoro la
soddisfazione dei bisogni
con i concetti delle gerarchie del campo
a me è capitato Recentemente un incontro
con dei giovani come voi e quando ho
dato il mio biglietto da visita e questo
ragazzo mi chiese Ma cosa vuol dire Cif
Executive officer e tra me abbiamo
pensato Mamma mia
siamo ancora e stiamo ancora utilizzando
una nomenclatura militare officer
L'azienda non è un esercito non è
un'armata è un gruppo di persone che
persegue un sogno e che cerca di fare
del bene comune possibilmente Quindi c'è
un profondo e una profonda
trasformazione che dobbiamo portare
avanti e poi questo devo ammettere si
sta facendo grandissimi progressi non
vedere più il profitto come un fine ma
mettere il profitto laddove deve stare
il profitto è un mezzo per raggiungere
un fine quindi quel periodo in cui
L'unica cosa che importava per le
aziende per gli amministratori delegati
per gli azionisti era massimizzare il
profitto e questo credo sia un periodo
che è definitivamente concluso E quindi
cosa cosa stiamo facendo come aziende
stiamo cercando di dare non più uffici
tradizionali ma ambienti belli ambienti
in cui le persone stiano bene che
abbiano voglia di tornare in ufficio
perché la relazione è fondamentale
vivere a contatto con le persone ciò che
ci nutre quindi dare ambienti che
facciano favorire le persone che
stimolano la collaborazione che
stimolino proprio il piacere di stare
insieme
passare dai bisogni standardizzati
primari secondari ai desideri sempre più
le aziende dovranno aiutare le persone a
realizzare i propri desideri questo è
chiaramente complesso perché mentre i
bisogni sono standard e diffusi i
desideri sono individuali e complicati
quindi non è facile e quindi serve una
nuova leadership sempre più bisogna
formare una classe dirigente del futuro
dei nuovi leader che abbiano queste
caratteristiche io le chiamo si chiama
il leader gentili che abbiano la
possibilità di caratterizzarsi con
questo di ascolto di empatia di voglia
di coinvolgere di ispirare le persone
per percorrere un viaggio insieme e da
ultimo le aziende si devono sempre più
concentrare nel raggiungimento di quello
che è il bene comune
stamattina sentivamo la leadership per
paradossi è un aspetto assolutamente
importante lo viviamo Ormai tutti i
giorni io lo vivo quotidianamente ci
sono aree in cui io posso guidare le
persone e ci sono delle aree ne
parlavamo anche poc'anzi delle nuove
tecnologie in cui noi dobbiamo essere
guidati dobbiamo accettare di non avere
le competenze giuste e in tutti i campi
ma di essere guidati magari da ragazzi e
ragazze giovani che capiscono più di noi
quello che sta succedendo
dobbiamo essere globali e locali
interessati alle comunità avere un
impatto alle comunità dobbiamo
chiedere e dare quindi deve cambiare la
figura del leader E qui ho rappresentato
un po' quello che in letteratura si
tende a dare un po' come aree delle
forze di un leader che è quello poi del
cuore testa e muscoli quindi testa
Ovviamente bisogna impostare una
strategia di un'azienda disegnare
come l'azienda funziona dobbiamo mettere
in campo le azioni per realizzare una
strategia ma soprattutto dobbiamo avere
cuore ascoltare le persone
coinvolgerle diventare dei leader che
ispirano le persone e che attirano e
trattengono i talenti nelle aziende E se
c'è una cosa che sta emergendo in tutta
la sua importanza e che negli anni che
verranno questo mix di queste tre
caratteristiche si sbilancerà in maniera
clamorosa l'aspetto del cuore quindi
mentre una leadership dei decenni
passati era È stata forse all'inizio
muscoli poi testa i muscoli poi
subentrato il cuore penso che il futuro
sarà caratterizzato da leader che
abbiano sempre più cuore vi lascio con
una frase una riflessione che questa
quindi tre frasi sul palazzo di Santiago
la frase di Napoleone e quest'ultima che
si trova non è stata citato pronunciata
il mese scorso Quindi siamo nel 1940 se
non commetto un errore grande dittatore
e Charlie Chaplin Il discorso finale
pronuncia questa frase pensiamo troppo e
sentiamo troppo poco quindi credo che
una delle dimensioni proprio per tornare
a trovare un nuovo equilibrio non solo
nella leadership ma nel mondo del lavoro
è proprio quello di tornare a sentire
cercare di entrare in risonanza con le
nuove generazioni che il ruolo così
importante avranno nelle aziende del
futuro e con questo vi lascio e vi
auguro un grande futuro per il mondo che
verrà Grazie